exposing themselves that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now day by day democrats are revealing
themselves they're anti-freedom
anti-science anti-religion anti-family
anti-gun anti-law enforcement and
anti-history
they've closed and militarized
washington and yet
they've left our borders wide open they
insist our country is systemically
racist
as they give china a pass on genocide
with the pace of destructive change
happening to our country
i know things may seem overwhelming well
this angle is for you for some
perspective
we need to step back a little bit now
for most of the time
think about this since reagan left
office the bipartisan establishment in
washington has been obsessed with
five really bad ideas number one
they believe that we have a labor
shortage here in the united states
so they want the borders as wide open
as possible now even now as as the
border is buckling under a surge of
illegals
the biden administration's biggest
concern isn't protecting americans
it's facilitating more mass migration
all i can do is communicate both to the
american public
and to the individuals seeking
protection they need to wait we are not
saying
don't come we are saying don't come now
because we will be able to deliver a
safe and orderly process to them as
quickly as possible
an orderly process
number two they believe that the ccp
will evolve and eventually become more
free meanwhile they'll make a ton of
money over there
so it was fine to help china become
richer and more powerful
well now we have a president who
welcomed rising china and now
thinks what most of us call genocide
it's just a different cultural norm
culturally there are different norms at
each country
and they their leaders are expected to
follow
well number three the establishment has
long believed that the future belongs to
social liberalism
so they want a supreme court that would
lean in that direction
well now democrats are emboldened enough
to think that they can ram through
radical legislation to erase protections
for religious freedom and then they
think they'll get the high court to go
along with it
i love talking about the equality act we
had for a long time
a series four things that we were going
to do
our fourth was not our doing it was the
courts was
marriage equality and the courts took
care of that
for us so the the piece that was
remaining of the four that we
set out to do a number of years ago is
the
uh now the equality act
does she realize that moving her hands
around doesn't make her any more logical
in her presentation
she needs actually a scroll underneath
her
because of the mask it is she loves
talking about the equality act
number four they believe that we should
bring democracy to the middle east
they want a permanent troop presence in
that part of the world
now just last week without congressional
approval joe biden mr peacenik himself
authorized airstrikes against
iranian-backed forces in
syria you can't act with impunity be
careful
be careful liz cheney and a handful of
other gop warhawks were fine with this
of course they welcomed it
number five the old bipartisan cabal
believes that
trade should never be restrained never
so they do
everything possible to make it easier
for companies to shift jobs
offshore so does joe biden have any
regrets about playing a key role
in that travesty of course not
you think in retrospect that you were
naive about china no here's the thing
here's the thing all of these policies
of course
a total disaster for most americans but
they were very popular with the donors
who funded both parties and so for
decades voters who disagreed with those
policies
they really didn't have anyone speaking
for them they had very few advocates
after eight years of george w bush with
his endless wars flat wages and non-stop
catch and release at the border a lot of
us on the right decided we had to go in
a different direction if we liked
president bush personally
at first we were known as the tea party
and our movement grew
more people started using the term
populist as well
and after we coalesced around donald
trump we had a leader who took our ideas
into the white house in less than a
decade we had beaten the leadership
of both parties it's one of the most
successful political movements in
american history
so taken by surprise the empire struck
back
they impeached president trump not once
but twice
they censored us online and drove many
into hiding into the cancel culture
they called us fascists and racists and
still do
they even changed the voting rules in
some states
and then they politicized a pandemic in
their pursuit
of power a few months ago
i think they thought that they were on
the verge of crushing us for good
but their landslide it never happened
the gop gained seats in the house and in
state legislatures
we gain support with hispanic hispanics
and african american working class
voters as well
for the establishment press who've never
been honest about our movement
cpac of course was just an excuse to
bring out their old fear-mongering and
trump hatred
but if you saw any of it you know how
upbeat about the future pretty much
everyone who was speaking there was
president trump was defiant and he vowed
to support
strong populist candidates in 2022
and florida governor ron desantis who's
showing how our principles can work in a
dynamic state like florida
was another star anyone can spout
conservative rhetoric
we can sit around and have academic
debates about conservative policy
and i'm not saying you don't do any of
that but the question is
when the clegg lights get hot when the
left comes after you
will you stay strong or will you fold
but when you do and you engage in the
battles ahead
hold the line stand your ground
and don't ever ever back down
thank you god bless you
you know the establishment is going to
try to kneecap him politically they
already kind of have tried
just like they did with president trump
they fear
desantis it's funny because these same
forces don't fear the ccp
they see china as their business partner
what they fear though
is seeing power go into the hands of the
middle class
hard-working americans who know their
rights
and who refuse to be cheated or
manipulated and who insist on fair wages
for their work
this explains why they're doing
everything possible
to sow hatred and division against and
between us
but we should relish this fight
democrats are exposing themselves as
frauds across the board
governors cuomo in new york new zeaman
california
pritzker and illinois and whitmer in
michigan
love locking down everyone except
criminals
and illegal immigrants and a bully like
cuomo
well he actually believed he deserved
his good press
but now even the democrats are
abandoning him
newsom is scrambling to try to get
schools to reopen in a state
only because he's facing a recall
41 years ago the conservatives led by
ronald reagan
took over the white house and saved this
country from an
era of decline and despair this
generation of conservatives now has the
organization
and policies that can do the same again
our ideas are already making life better
for millions in the red states
but we're not going to stop there this
must be
a 50-state movement devoted to uplifting
the whole country
and we're not going to stop until our
mission is complete
and that's the angle